and Morrissey in your new book going red
who are the two million voters that you
talk about in this book the two million
voters refers to voters in seven key
counties in seven key swing states that
Republicans won in 2004 but lost in 2008
and 2012 and so we're looking at
bellwether counties in places like
Florida Virginia Ohio North Carolina New
Hampshire Colorado and Wisconsin
Wisconsin is actually kind of an
interesting case because Republicans
haven't actually quite won wisconsin yet
but because of some of the changes that
have occurred over the last few years in
wisconsin i think they had a pretty good
opportunity there the idea is is to find
out who those voters are because the the
key theory in this book is that the
reason why Republicans win local and
state elections in those counties but
can't win presidential elections is
because they have lost touch with who
the voters are at the national the
national level has lost touch with who
the voters are on the local level let's
go to Hamilton County Ohio Cincinnati
basic yes who are some of the voters in
your view that the Republicans have lost
and how can they get them back
that's an interesting case actually
Hamilton County is an interesting case
because it's the only County that had a
net population loss over the last few
decades all the rest of these the
challenges are more about population
growth people coming in from other parts
of the country carrying their maybe what
you call their native political
predilections with them Hamilton County
is the one where people have actually
left and they've had a pretty
significant population decrease over the
last 30 to 40 years so the people who
are left are the people who didn't
really have the economic mobility to
have those options to leave and so
you're talking about blue-collar workers
people who work hard they don't work and
necessarily in in high-priced firms
they're they're working with their hands
that you're working to put food on the
table and Republicans have an
opportunity to make a case for economic
Liberty based on knowing who those
particular people are in Hamilton and
what their particular issues are the
problem that you have though with
Republican Party and Hamilton I should
mention by the
I was at one point one of the most
Republican counties in a very Republican
State even when Ohio would occasionally
vote for a Democrat for instance with
Bill Clinton Hamilton County was very
Republican and it was it was a very red
County and over the last two
presidential elections they voted for
Barack Obama became a very blue county
and and so one of the reasons is that
Republicans will will message on say the
economy by using an ideological
philosophical argument that's what I say
is pitched at the 30,000 foot level you
know free markets lower regulation but
that's all they don't talk about the
fact that for instance in Cincinnati the
EPA is requiring the city of Cincinnati
to separate their sewage system from
their storm drain system it's a very
expensive project it's a this is
something that they've been doing with
other cities around the country as well
these are older cities that had sort of
a merged system and they want them to
separate it out the city of Cincinnati
put together a plan to comply with the
EPA the EPA accepted it and then after
that they discovered that they could do
it for about forty percent less and
still meet all of the EPA's goals and
the EPA refused to reopen reopen the
issue so as a result you have people who
are going to pay hundreds of dollars a
year in extra utilities costs in a city
where people don't really have that kind
of disposable income just because the
EPA will not go back and and reopen that
process and allow the city of Cincinnati
to do it you know less expensively more
efficiently so if you're going to come
in and talk about regulation stifling
local economies and taking money out of
your pocket as a presidential candidate
you should know about this about this
issue with the metropolitan water
district and why it's costing them
hundreds of millions of dollars more
than it should and why that money's
going to come directly out of the
pockets of the constituents there if you
talk about that that makes the economic
issue the economic argument much more
personal there's a much more there's a
much greater economic connection now
that's what Barack Obama did in 2008 and
2012 he learned about these communities
through this fabulous organization this
fabulous network of people
he rolled out across the country and so
when they were talking about issues like
the economy and talking about issues
like making government work better they
would look for these local issues that
would get their ambassadors to talk
about this and say these are the types
of things that I'm gonna fix when I
become president and that's the reason
one of them one of the reasons not
hardly the only reason but it's one of
the reasons why people had such an
emotional connection to their vote for
Barack Obama in 2008 and why it's
sustained for 2012 the states you've
picked and looked at here all
essentially must wins for the
Republicans easily win the presidency
Florida Wisconsin Ohio Colorado why is
Wisconsin a special case it's
interesting because of course
Republicans haven't won Wisconsin except
in huge landslide election victories for
instance Ronald Reagan won Wisconsin
twice in in his elections but normally
this is a state that stays pretty blue
Scott Walker
got elected in 2010 and put in place the
act 10 reforms it's a very divisive
issue and in the state of Wisconsin but
it's paid a lot of dividends and in fact
one study that just came out in March
hurts me in late February showed that
the state the state and local
governments have saved about five
billion dollars over five years thanks
to the ak10 reforms so they were able to
stay away from layoffs they were able to
use money wisely that's the type of
message of course that Republicans are
talking about usually when they're
talking about trimming government and
and trimming regulations and making
things work more efficiently so there's
an opening there for the Republican
message that Scott Walker and the
Wisconsin Republicans have opened up
that's ten electoral college votes so
that's better than Colorado that's
better than certainly better than New
Hampshire New Hampshire's four electoral
college votes usually considered a
pretty key state for both parties to win
because it says something about the
reach of their national message
Wisconsin if Republicans could take
Wisconsin out of the Democrats column
and put it into their column but I
really do think it's feasible to do that
then that really resets the whole
Midwest and Rust Belt for Republicans in
a way and winning Wisconsin would show
that kind of strength throughout that
entire region that would be very
difficult for Democrats to counter and
Morrissey what is your day job my day
job I work at hot air calm I'm senior
editor at hot air comm I do a I do a
twice a week podcast on politics and
culture and also I write columns for the
fiscal times and for the week in this
election season have any of the
candidates done what you're suggesting
here in going red you know I think if
you take a look at the primary the
primary races so far I think Ted Cruz
actually done a very good job of getting
on the ground in Iowa especially but
also in Texas I mean he knows Texas very
well it's his home state apparently in
Oklahoma as well we're hearing a lot of
things about the Ted Cruz's organization
that that tend to make me think that
he's on the right track in terms of what
we're talking about here with the
exception of Iowa which is which is kind
of a purple state you know Oklahoma in
Texas is pretty easy these are very red
states and so we don't necessarily know
how he's pulling in swing voters in
those states and again it's a fractured
primary - so then you're only working
within the Republican Party primary so
there's it's not a great analog
necessarily but the organizational level
is there for Ted Cruz I think Marco
Rubio's organization is pretty decent as
well Donald Trump is of course the
variable because if the Republican Party
in 2008 and 2012 were at the 30,000 foot
level in terms of messaging Donald
Trump's really kinda at the 40,000 foot
level right he's very punchy concepts
only and doesn't necessarily offer a
detailed substance behind it but he just
talked about this is my commitment I'm
going to do this I'm gonna make this
work make this work I'm gonna win I'm
gonna make this great and people are
responding to that in the primaries so
it's interesting to see how that will
work out if Donald Trump is the nominee
does he switch to a ground game of the
type that is described in going red or
does he try to stay at that 40,000 foot
level or 30,000 foot level and see if he
can bring in people through just sheer
messaging and celebrity status alone be
an interesting test
and Morrissey's new book is called going
read the 2 million voters who will elect
the next president and how conservatives
can win them this is book TV on c-span -
[Music]
when I do